All that we are, who we are, what we think and what we feel is due to our brain
chemistry. We're like walking chemical factories producing the chemicals that
we need to function daily. However, sometimes these chemicals can change and
this change can affect our mood, our ability to learn and remember, and even
our behavior. For example, our brains produce and use dopamine which is a
neurotransmitter responsible for a reward behavior such as having sex or eating
a good meal. Now, some drugs can increase the amount of a neurotransmitter
that's available. For example, methamphetamines increase the amount of dopamine
that's available. This can result in a person feeling really great when they're
under the influence. The feeling of euphoria. However, there are negative
effects associated with excessive dopamine levels. For example, stimuli-induced
psychosis. In this part of the lesson, we're going to talk about three main
classes of drugs. Stimulants, depressants and hallucinogens. I'm going to send
you over to Susan to get started on our discussion of stimulants.